it's Friday and that means it's time for
Dan bond Gino's news explosion this week
the theme of course the Muller report
our favorite former new york city cop
and secret service agent is here to give
us his top three supposed to take away
from the port and as you listen to what
Dan bond Gino says see if you catch him
using the word um or hmm we're pausing
at all no he is the most complete
sentence speaker you will ever meet in
your entire life dan bungee no gosh no
prompter either I don't even put notes
on my hands or anything this is all
natural buddy that's right alright so
here are my three stories before we get
to the Muller stuff story number three I
gotta go back to CPL buddy ya have a
naughty Franken CNN a creation of CNN
you know the more we find out about this
guy the more the creepy he becomes it's
amazing tucker has there ever been a
less impressive human being on cable
news upon him on a wider breadth of
topics as you know he was on this show
called reliable sources
that's the funniest part of this whole
thing like listen brian Stelter changed
the title of the show after avenatti
there's clips aren't going anywhere we
saw them they're out there forever this
shows that it's not reliable sources now
it's unreliable sources it's good it's
gotta be at best you can't go back to
that sense with the sale
alright story number two getting back to
the Muller report the critical critical
take away it's not what was in the
Muller report that fascinated me and I'm
through about 90% of it just got to get
to the GRU stuff it's what's not in it
now Tucker we've all been told by you
know the the the the brilliant academics
and media people after that as you know
are much smarter than you and I wait we
are the great unwashed and the dumb ones
they have told us that Muller was this
demigod was going to expose Russian
collusion right but what he conveniently
leaves out of it is that some of the
people who made that Trump Tower meeting
happened the Russians were in fact
connected to Hillary Clinton
refusion GPS the company she paid and
personal relationships already
acknowledged in the media I thought we
were investigating Russian collusion I'm
not sure that's what Muller was doing I
think what he was doing to quote Mark
Levin this morning is he was writing an
op-ed for 30 30 million that me ask you
one on one question yeah do you think
what you just said explains the puzzling
fact that we haven't heard I don't think
we've heard from Hillary Clinton on the
release of the Moller report
Tucker they she has a lot to hide Rinat
Akhmetov intel connected allegedly
individual showed up for the russian
trump tower meeting and the russian
lawyer both had ties to clinton and
business ties diffusion gps this is
documented fact anybody can look it up
on the interweb out there to make a joke
of it you can check it out yourself but
again nowhere in the Muller report are
those relationships mentioned it's
basically a Jack Ryan story told to make
you believe Trump colluded with the
Russians so they can get a roadmap for
impeachment that's what it is well yeah
which is incredible story number one is
how did they blow this the American
media was completely humiliated Tucker
they got the story totally backwards
from the start they told us collusion
was real and the spy scandal was fake we
were all conspiracy theorists the story
was actually the spying scandal is very
real and collusion was faked and one
quick thing and it were running out of
time here but I find that ironic that
they keep patting themselves on the back
for getting minor details of the story
right it's like going to a bank robbery
reporting on a bank robbery that never
happened and then celebrating that you
got the color of the car the guy left
then right and patting yourself on the
back like Jim it got still good job Jim
great job a bank robbery that never
happened I would say by the way this
show actually did get it right from day
one we even found ourselves in the back
that single time and we're not going to
now Dan bungee no you're the best and I
hope you have a great Easter weekend you
too buddy thank you thank you
we're out of time